hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Matt Welch
we're doing a still libertarian 2012 and
we're celebrating the forthcoming
release of the Declaration of
Independence in a new updated paperback
edition our question now comes from
Christina Tate via email she asked why
am I not just throwing away a vote in
essence helping Barack Obama get
reelected if i vote for gary johnson the
Libertarian Party candidate put another
way should libertarians be content to ax
men in ties the eshet on in the
theological sense of hastening the chaos
of the final judgment Matt it took us
eight takes to get that pronunciation
correct what's that no that was pretty
good anyways um that's one way of
looking at it i would suggest there's
also another way of looking at it which
is to say what do you expect out of Mitt
Romney that's going to be different than
Barack Obama do you expect him to be
more forthright in tackling the problem
with entitlements coming down the future
because that isn't how he has campaigned
he campaigned to the left of Rick Perry
on Social Security blasted Rick Perry
for calling social security of Ponzi
scheme he's campaigned to the left of
Barack Obama on Medicare he's good
ridiculing Obama and pillorying him for
cutting Medicare on the campaign trail
and in terms of military spending he has
said that we should pin GDP growth all
of the private sector growth that we
come up with in this country from here
on time in memoriam needs to be paid
four percent of that needs to go to
military spending so I'm not sure
exactly from a libertarian economic
point of view what Mitt Romney is
bringing to the table that's going to be
considerably better than Barack Obama
I'm not saying that he's going to be
worse but ask yourself what you're going
to get in return out of out of this on
the other hand as we point out
repeatedly in the book whenever
constituencies within any tents
democratic-republican or smaller tents
out there can be taken for granted they
are going to be and the concerns that
animate them the most are going to be
ignored you see this on the Democratic
side when it comes to things like the
drug war Barack Obama has been worse
than george w bush i think by any
objective measure in doing things like
rating medical marijuana dispensaries
but he can do it because what are they
going to do vote for Mitt Romney now in
California they're probably not so for
those who feel like
libertarian Republicans or sort of
right-leaning small government types
think you have to ask yourself at what
point are you going to get their
attention it's an individual decision
not telling me here what to do but
there's a lot of different things to
think about rather than just the binary
am i throwing my vote away I'm pretty
much of the opinion that you're throwing
your vote away if you vote for Barack
Obama or for Mitt Romney reason doesn't
endorse candidates as a magazine or as
foundation or anything I'm planning at
this point on voting for Gary Johnson
because his platform at the presidential
level most closely comes to what I think
the government should be doing so I
don't see that as a wasted vote and if
Barack Obama gets elected or Mitt Romney
it's not because they didn't win my vote
or I didn't hold my nose in vote for him
it's because neither of that neither of
them got my vote because they didn't
earn it ask a libertarian 2012 comes
back after this commercial message
you